um okay
um thank you this is really incredible
um thank you to the Hollywood Chamber of
Commerce because I'm so honored uh I'm
actually I hate speaking in public it
terrifies me
um I hate which is why I don't present
unless I'm literally holding on to Lisa
and Jennifer
uh
I um
I might cry I will forget to thank
certain people I might embarrass myself
and say something I regret but I want to
start by thanking my beautiful friends
Laura and Lisa and Jen
already gonna cry
um just because I love you all so much
and it's so nice that you
um came out and showed up for me in
public the way you do so often in
private
I love you okay
that's done one tier okay
um anyway uh I just want to thank
everybody who's responsible for making
this happen and that um I'm gonna start
with my long suffering
houses Melissa uh she's incredible
um
she gave me bullet points for the speech
and if erupted her I literally would
think every single person here and it
would take forever but uh so thank you
um to Paramount and Spyglass and Warner
Brothers television uh Channing Dunning
and uh to Jeff Hirsch who's been such a
supporter of she shining Veil
and everyone at stars Cathy Catherine
and Ally uh thank you
um anyway this is just this is really
surreal because I'm from Birmingham
Alabama
and uh well the only time that you see
your name on a sidewalk is if you did it
yourself with a stick and the wet cement
uh so anyway everyone thinks I got my
start as the girl who danced with Bruce
Springsteen on stage but my real start
came when I uh oh I'm not even crying
that's just actual my nose running
um I really got my start as
um you know when I was chosen at 12 to
be Anna in The King and I at Camp Mack
yeah
um Camp Mack that was famous for being
spelled
the same forwards and backwards Camp Mac
Camp Mac think about it it's also known
as a palindrome which I learned from
Johnny this morning thank you
um anyway so as you know this business
can be really tricky
um and after playing Anna I did have
pretty big career low
uh
but since then I've been really blessed
to be a part of some very successful
long-standing projects and I've been
lucky to work with some of the best
piece people in this business and to
name a few
um friends creators Marta David and
Kevin
uh Cougar Town Bill Lawrence uh then
there's Kevin Williamson and the late
great Wes Craven who created the Supreme
franchise
and uh how gross I'm just like
sorry Coco I'm sure you feel great uh
Wes Craven
what
bring the mic down okay
um with uh who created the scream
franchise I'm Kevin Williamson okay and
now with my new show shining Veil I
still get to work with the most talented
people I like Sharon Horgan and the
show's Creator Jeff astroth
um who never ever leaves the office so
thank you for being here you can go now
no go no no no don't go not yet
not yet
so consistency and uh long-standing
relationships are really really
important to me and so I want to thank
my incredible manager
and friend
I love her uh Cynthia pet and my my
loyal agents Gabby Morgan and Richard
whites and
um my
honest which is to me the most important
thing
um
my business manager for over 30 years
Rick Shepherd
and I want to thank my amazing assistant
Tracy Reese who uh
yeah
she may not get me jobs but she um sure
helps me keep them
um
so I'm still in the process of working
on my longest and most important
projects
thank you John for teaching me to be a
better person
and thank you Coco for reminding me
every day that I'm not
um no seriously
oh
Coco that means that I do a bad job
you're perfect
um no seriously Coco it's not easy to
grow up in this business and I just um I
just want you to know you shine and
you shine in your own unique light and I
love you so much and so proud of you I'm
proud to be your mom
and uh John
e some people call him up
um Johnny John uh you're such an amazing
and talented person and I'm I'm so lucky
to be with you
[Applause]
if I read the speech that John wrote for
me
it would be a hit song for sure and also
seven minutes too long okay so um I also
want to thank my beautiful sisters
Dottie in Virginia for showing up for me
today flying in here
my mom would have loved this so much but
my dad was obsessed with television and
wow
sorry Dad whoa
all right
seriously
um
anyway my dad loves television movies
and all entertainment and early on in my
career there was a point where I had no
money left at all I was down to two
weeks to live to actually live
um to support myself and I called my dad
up and he's like CeCe you need to come
home it is a long fall from Hollywood to
Alabama and you know what you're a
Salesman you're damn good salesman so
you need to come home and do what you do
best
sell swimming pools
um then
the uh next day I got the pardon Family
Ties
so
this will make me cry because I do love
my dad I was just want to say I know
he's really proud of me and
um it does look like I'm here to stay
[Applause]
to be here today to speak on your behalf
as your co-workers your friends and your
your family your sisters
[Applause]
um yeah and that's happened since we've
known you for a very long time yeah no
that's it's been nice for since we met
30 almost 30 years ago no not 30 years
that's a typo no it's not
are you sure yeah okay well anyway
um
to be friends with Courtney is to be
family with Courtney
um and she is responsible for all of
that from the beginning of when we met
her she was immediately inclusive yeah
warm loving interested in everything
about you and you know I was really
nervous to meet her because I was a huge
fan I would see her in I remember seeing
her at the flowering tree a yogurt store
that we would go to and I I panicked I
sweat and I just didn't know what she
was going to be like when we we got our
job now we got to meet her yeah me too
also so beautiful and famous yes very
because she was no because she was the
only one of the cast who was famous
that's right so I feel like we were all
sort of like taking our cues from her
yeah first to see what the Courtney Cox
show was going to be the star of Misfits
of science
what else you were the only famous one
oh no you were known you were Courtney
Cox and her attention to detail okay
this is it's very intense um you you
really want to hope that you don't have
any kind of like a stain or a spot on a
wall or or that a pillow is out of place
or that or a hair or something that
needs to be plucked or
um luckily I can't see that well anymore
oh oh you can
you can
I know and and if the crook so I'm just
saying thank God this this star is
straight because that would really
and this is something that kind of I've
been worrying about Courtney and I want
you to know this and thank God for your
home court line because you have that
spray but this very clean star that you
will be laying on or squatting on I
don't know what you're gonna do on it
but eventually people will be walking on
it with their shoes
that um might drive you crazy but just
know that it's it's okay that's what
it's meant for yeah and thank you thank
you enriching our lives personally yeah
and as fans we want to thank you for
making us laugh
watching you on screen and just in life
in general you're one of the funniest
human beings on the planet Earth nothing
makes me happier than a Courtney joke
and always making us smile and thank you
for enriching our lives with your work
we are so proud of you we love you your
sisters from another mister and we love
you
thank you